[Música]
Hola Aquí comienza la crónica de medio
ambiente de France 24 yo soy María Clara
calle Esta es una semana clave para los
ecosistemas marinos en Lisboa se realiza
la décima Cumbre mundial de los océanos
y Panamá acoge el encuentro nuestros
océanos El primero está más dedicado al
sector privado y ambos le apuestan a
encontrar soluciones Pues en ninguna de
estas Cumbres se negocian acuerdos como
si ocurre con las reuniones programadas
por la ONU y precisamente lo que se
necesitan son acciones pues las
actividades de los humanos están
poniendo en grave peligro a mares y ríos
actualmente hay cinco amenazas latentes
según el último informe sobre cómo
avanzan los objetivos de desarrollo
sostenible publicado en 2022 por la ONU
sobre el objetivo 14 dedicado a la vida
submarina este reporte demuestra que la
contaminación Marina viene
principalmente de la tierra por las
basuras y el plástico otras amenazas son
la sobrepesca y la acidificación que es
el aumento de los ácidos por la cantidad
de CO2 que absorben los océanos y entre
más ácidas sean las aguas menos
organismos podrán vivir allí Además está
el calentamiento de las aguas marinas y
la eutrofización que es el incremento de
fitoplancton sobre la superficie de ríos
y lagos por los residuos que lanzan los
humanos aquello impide que los rayos del
sol entren al agua y así se reduce el
oxígeno de peces y plantas
todo esto pone contra la pared a los
océanos que son los ecosistemas más
grandes del mundo y su protección es
vital porque absorben una cuarta parte
de todo el dióxido de carbono que
produce la humanidad cada año
amortiguando Así el calentamiento global
además los mares y océanos están
directamente relacionados con los ciclos
de lluvias el agua potable que
consumimos el oxígeno que respiramos y
son la Fuente principal de proteína para
casi el 40% de la población mundial
precisamente por su importancia en la
cop 15 de biodiversidad que se realizó
en diciembre del año pasado en Canadá
los países pactaron un acuerdo histórico
la meta de proteger el 30% de
ecosistemas marinos y terrestres de todo
el mundo si se logra será un cambio
radical pues desde 1992 que se habla de
conservación solo se ha protegido un
8,16% de los océanos según nos explicó
subjefe del equipo glo bal de la ONU
para el fondo mundial para los arrecifes
de coral desde la Cumbre de los océanos
en Lisboa él nos dijo Por qué considera
importante la llamada meta del 30 por 30
creo que lo más importante es que ahora
tenemos las puntadas políticas sobre la
mesa hay mucho compromiso de todos los
países tanto desarrollados como como en
vías de desarrollo de lograr esta meta
por qué Porque todos entendemos de que
realmente no es nuestra vida nuestra
economía nuestra manera de vivir como
especie humana está obviamente ligada a
los recursos naturales de los que
dependemos y yo creo que que La amenaza
hoy día ya ha incrementado tanto en
términos de la degradación de nuestros
ecosistemas que ya los diferentes
sectores incluyendo el sector privado
entiende que si no tomamos esas acciones
ahora de protección Si no aseguramos
nuestro capital natural no vamos a tener
el estilo de vida ni la forma de vida
que que hoy día llevamos
entonces realmente es un momento de
inflexión este este acuerdo y ahora lo
que necesitamos es la voluntad política
se mantenga y también tener los recursos
económicos que tienen que de gobiernos
de sector privado y otros mecanismos
innovadores esta protección es vital en
ecosistemas como los arrecifes de coral
pues son esenciales en la captura de
carbono y son el hogar del 25% de todas
las especies marinas sin embargo están
muy amenazados de hecho el 20% de los
arrecifes ya están destruidos el 24%
restante enfrenta un peligro inminente
de desaparición y el 26% podría
extinguirse a largo plazo todo esto
según la ONU ya vanex nos habló del
panorama de los arrecifes de coral en el
mundo la situación es crítica realmente
estamos en un proceso de declive de
ecosistema que es importantísimo alberga
veinticinco por ciento de la
biodiversidad Marina en el planeta y si
no tomamos las acciones ahora ese ese
declive va a continuar de hecho
tomando en cuenta el la cantidad de
cordales que tenemos hoy día de aquí a
30 años si no tomamos acción ahora
podemos perder hasta 90 por ciento de
los arrecifes de coral que que nos
quedan en el planeta hoy día y por eso
es tan importante el acuerdo al que se
llegó en Montreal durante la Cumbre de
la convención de biodiversidad Aunque la
situación es crítica también hay
soluciones una de ellas es promover una
economía que sea sostenible con los
océanos otras posibles vías son ayudar a
regenerar los ecosistemas marinos por
ejemplo promoviendo la siembra de coral
o disminuir los plásticos que terminan
en mares y ríos y contribuir a la
limpieza de los océanos desde el fondo
mundial para los arrecifes de coral
lideran varias iniciativas y ya vanex
nos contó algunas de ellas
un par de ejemplos muy sencillos estamos
trabajando nosotros trabajamos en
maricultura que es por ejemplo el
cultivo Por decirlo así de especies
marinas que pueden ayudar en la en el
manejo de los arrecifes de coral y a la
misma al revés ofrecer una alternativa
económica para las personas uno de los
grandes problemas que tenemos en el
planeta son los residuos tóxicos
de desechos líquidos y plásticos que
realmente afectan mucho a los accidentes
de coral y nosotros
en diferentes iniciativas que buscan
fomentar
el recogido de plásticos de los océanos
y utilizarlos con materia prima para
para nuevos productos crear nuevos
ciclos de economía y cosas por el estilo
así terminamos nuestra Crónica de medio
ambiente pueden ver este y todos los
capítulos en France 24.com hasta la
próxima